wie steht als nächster kommt der hat
zumindest als eine auswirkung von
thüringen die vertrauensfrage gestellt
im parteivorstand und wurde dort
bestätigt von 36 mitgliedern stimmten 33
mit ja und sprachen ihm das vertrauen
aus meine kolleginnen und kollegen in
thüringen hat eine feier demokrat für
das amt des ministerpräsidenten
kandidieren wollen um für seine
fünfköpfige fraktion ein signal für die
politische mitte zu setzen
er wurde aber gewählt mit stimmen der
fdp der cdu und vor allem stimmen der
afg und dadurch wurden die motive dieser
kandidatur in ihr gegenteil verkehrt
wir sind verletzt ja wir zweifel an
unserer klaren haltung als demokratische
partei der mitte geweckt haben und wir
sind beschämt weil wir der afg
ermöglicht haben uns und darüber hinaus
die parlamentarische demokratie zu
verhöhnen und dafür entschuldige ich
mich namens der freien demokraten
die freien demokraten tragen
verantwortung für den schaden von
thüringen
dieser verantwortung haben wir uns aber
gestellt und bin und 24 stunden die
notwendigen ersten konsequenzen gezogen
anders als hier gesagt worden ist von
der kollegin der linken von dem kollegen
der spd und anders als die afg zuruft
ich habe nicht am mittwoch in einer
ersten reaktion viel glück gewünscht
ich habe mein amt als parteivorsitzender
an die klare abgrenzung der fdp
von jeder kooperation mit der afg
gefunden und dabei wird es allein nicht
bleiben
dabei wird es allein nicht bleiben wir
arbeiten grundlegend auf und unterziehen
uns einer prüfung dazu setzen wir eine
arbeitsgruppe unter leitung unseres
experten für rechtsextremismus benjamin
strasser ein
sie wird neue negative und methoden der
afg sowie deren einfluss und unsere
reaktion darauf untersuchen dazu werden
wir auch ratschläge von außen höheren
erfurt war ein fehler aber wir
unternehmen alles damit er sich nicht
wiederholen kann
die entscheidung im thüringer landtag
waren nicht ausdruck einer neuen
position der fdp sondern anlass für eine
bestätigung unserer haltung mit einer
partei wie der afd kann es keine
kooperation geben wir sind nicht die
steigbügelhalter zu machen ingo lanz
helgoland sie haben hier heute von
bürgerlichen regierungen dann
bürgerlichen lager gesprochen und das
passt hier einer neuen erzählt strang
der afg waren es früher die altparteien
so sprechen sie jetzt von einem
angeblichen bürgerlichen lager mit cdu
und fdp
die fdf de vertritt in wahrheit ein
denken völkischer überlegenheit
fantasien das auf ausgrenzung und anti
liberalität basiert zumal in thüringen
helgolands zumal in thüringen versucht
die afg sich in anknüpfung an den
nationalsozialismus die afd ist nichts
war nichts und wird nie teil eines
bürgerlichen lagers sein sondern im
gegenteil wenn sie von bürgerlichkeit
sprechen dann wollen sie sich nur selbst
verharmlosen und sie entwerten dem
begriff des bürgersinns damit
und das herz
und das hat der fünfte federer doch
selbst gezeigt ihn loben ihre vordenker
als neue feine varianz im taktischen
arsenal der afd
ihr öffentliches angebot an einer
beteiligung an der regierung haben union
und fdp abgelehnt
im thüringer landtag haben sie dann
einen eigenen kandidaten vorgeschlagen
und zum ersten mal in der geschichte des
deutschen parlamentarismus haben sie
diesen kandidaten dann selbst nicht
gewählt vor stattdessen im geheimen
einen anderen kandidaten
sie sprechen hier von normalität und
demokratie in bauland in wahrheit war es
destruktion und das ist nicht fein und
taktisch das ist verschlagen und er los
was sie gemacht haben
wir sind feierte anwesende liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind mit
kritik konfrontiert und wir nehmen
kritik an
wenn aber fdp und afd gleichgesetzt
werden wenn jüdische kommunalpolitiker
der fdp in frankfurt als nazis
beschimpft werden wenn parteibüros
diffamiert und geschmiert werden wenn
die kinder von fdp mitgliedern
angegangen werden dann werden wir uns
zur wehr setzen
wir haben einen fehler gemacht
wir haben einen fehler gemacht den wir
aufarbeiten
wenn aber der versuch unternommen wird
diesen fehler zu instrumentalisieren um
uns auch in anderen fragen mundtot zu
machen dann werden wir uns nicht
einschüchtern lassen
wir haben rasch vorführen lassen
mein letzter gedanke wir haben uns
vorführen lassen von ganz rechts und nun
wird von ganz links dasselbe versucht
alles was man schon immer an der fdp
abgelehnt hat kommt nun ein topf mit
erfurt von jamaika bis zur klimapolitik
und auch da darf sich niemand täuschen
auch in polarisierten zeiten werden wir
weiter für freiheit rechtsstaat unser
verständnis von marktwirtschaft und die
politische mitte unsere stimmen erheben
christian lindner partei- und
fraktionschef der liberalen ja fehler
und bedauern
das hat er in der vergangenen woche
häufiger schon wiederholt aber
bemerkenswert heute noch einmal ganz
klar und deutlich ich entschuldige mich
sagte er im namen der freien demokraten
[Musik]